Marty just sit down and eat with us this
isn't real life it's just another one of
Rick's stupid promo commercials I'm not
eating Rick will you please explain to
Morley that this isn't a promo
commercial and that we're trying to have
a nice family Thanksgiving dinner
together I can't do that Jerry because
Morty's right promo commercial right now
what what are you talking about what the
hell is a promo commercial anyone
disposable advertisement it's
meaningless it does it doesn't matter
this is it's it's gonna misrepresent the
show it's gonna it's gonna give a bad
first impression I told you dad no I
spent hours preparing this dinner this
can't be a promo commercial you're lying
Beth summer do something I'm not gonna
help you Jerry because aliens try to
catch me and Morty because guess why
we're we're a couple of intergalactic
criminals pretty crazy huh it doesn't
matter because none of this has anything
to do with the show Morty it's not like
it's the fugitive we're and we're on the
run every single week so hey Rick what's
the show about anyway oh this is a crazy
sci-fi show Morty oh oh all kinds of
wild stuff happens each week each
episodes like a little mini sci-fi
adventure movie morning well Rick I'm
pretty impressed about that are my mom
and dad and sister in the show too or is
it just you and me now they're in a -
Morty
they have something to do while we're
out on adventures or whatever listen I
don't care anymore Morty I don't want to
talk about it I'm gonna tell your dad
that he's an idiot
I'm gonna go in the garage huh
welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have brand new rick and morty season
four to break down a whole bunch of
easter eggs in a much better idea for
when the actual season four episode one
release date is going to be I'm doing
Rick and Morty merch giveaways and all
my Rick and Morty videos all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your best season for word theory on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this this promo like a lot of the
promos that they released in the
commercials is morty yelling at Rick for
selling them out because it's made is an
advertisement for the show the thing
about this one this is different from
the other commercials that they make
with them is that there's no actual real
product that they're trying to advertise
because a lot of brands will use Rick
and Morty to advertise their products
Adult Swim makes way more money on it so
they're really happy to do that and when
they do them really well like a couple
of them they wind up being pretty funny
these are the old spice in the Hardee's
commercial premise but there's some of
the better ones that they've done why
you got to keep selling us out brick
usually it's a really simple premise
from the first few seasons of the show
that doesn't require a lot of intensive
animation letting them reuse backgrounds
like Morty's room other times they'll
keep it even simpler than that in terms
of animation a number of characters like
the mr. poopy butthole Thanksgiving
trailer from two years ago I'll play
that in a second too the reason why this
new Thanksgiving themed promo is more
important is because season four was
announced for November release date 2019
we now actually know when it's going to
drop thanks to the Adult Swim festival
that's happening in November if you live
near Los Angeles and you haven't seen
any of the promos that they've been
releasing for that specifically they're
doing a special festival like they did
last year they take a bunch of new
content from all their biggest shows
featured during a live music festival
this year it's Friday November 15th and
Saturday November 16th during that
festival they finally confirmed that
they're gonna do an early screening of
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 1 I
believe it's gonna be on Saturday
November 16th it's the entire episode
without commercials it's only 22 minutes
long so it's not quite as long as it
seems so if you can make it to that
festival you have a chance to see the
first episode before anyone else but
here's the thing though some of you have
probably already connected the dots and
figured this out the official premiere
of Rick and Morty season 4 episode 1 is
the day after that Sunday November 17th
so you do get to see the episode before
everyone else but only like a day before
everyone else upside is if you can't
make it to that festival in Los Angeles
you don't have to wait forever listening
to everyone else talk about the episode
with you having not seen it they also
confirmed that most of their new merch
this year is holiday themed merch
designed to take advantage of all the
major holidays that season four is going
to overlap with you have Thanksgiving
Black Friday Christmas or whatever
winter themed holiday you celebrate
that's been taken over by commercialism
and gift buying New Year's and even the
Super Bowl I'll explain what the episode
schedule is going to be because if you
remember way back to Rick and Morty
season 1 they dropped that at the very
end of the year it's gonna be a lot like
that they probably could have released
season 4 a little bit sooner but they
don't make a lot of money on advertising
from the episodes when they air on TV
like a normal TV show would most
animated shows make their money on
syndication and merch sales so if you
really want to support the show watching
it live on TV when it first aired helps
their ratings but it's even bigger for
them if you buy their merch and all you
conspiracy theorists will love how this
played out because after the season 3
post-credit scene with mr. poopy
butthole going on and on about having a
big white Santa Claus beard the next
time we see him they were not wrong in
calling their shot babe ruth's style
there were a lot of people after that
post-credit scene who thought that they
had secretly made some sort of Christmas
special episode Doctor Who style and
would drop it without warning like they
did with the April Fool's Day episode
surprise here's an episode that we
were announced we're going like what do
you want me to do wave a magic wand and
just make the premiere of Rick and Marty
happen just cuz you asked and knowing
that he'd go yeah I do like alright you
get this one we later found out that was
not the case as we entered that giant
break while they were in the middle of
their contract war for the Mega 70
episode renewal there was no special
bonus Christmas episode there was a
surprise
Thanksgiving trailer that they drop with
mr. poopy butthole which I'll talk about
in a second but if you were one of those
conspiracy theorists technically you
were not wrong there was a Christmas
themed episode that they're dropping is
just they weren't gonna drop it for two
years the whole thing with that 70
episode contract renewal and the super
long break is that they finished
delivering season three in entered
renegotiations in their contract for the
next big batch of episodes but because
they were pushing for 70 the network
didn't want to do that and that's what
led to that super long break it took
them almost nine months to work out that
new deal and while that was happening no
new work on episodes was happening but
whether or not they originally intended
on doing it Thanksgiving season for
launch
they also Babe Ruth style called their
shot just a couple months after the end
of season three ended when they posted
this mr. poopy butthole Thanksgiving
trailer almost two years to the exact
day that season four is going to
premiere
[Music]
if you don't remember what that was all
about that was them adding a whole bunch
of backstory and Easter eggs between
that season to post-credits scene where
you saw him downing all those pills and
going crazy in the season 3 post-credit
scene where you meet his wife and child
all the places that they go in this
scrapbook are the same places that rick
and morty go during a lot of their
season 3 episodes so which is them
continuing the joke of the idea that mr.
poopy butthole is a canonical character
and not some made-up person from
someone's mind like he was during the
parasite episode in season 2 thanks mr.
poopy butthole I always could count on
you like what are you talking about I've
been here this whole time
but because they're doing so many
holidays in such a short amount of time
I'm only expecting like two real holiday
themed episodes this year and maybe just
a Christmas episode if you don't
remember what season one first aired
because it's been 84 years since season
1 they drop that at the beginning of
December anatomy Park was episode 3 they
aired that the week before Christmas
that year they planned it that way from
the beginning that's what we got our
giant floating hobo Santa and all Rick's
still salty about Pirates of the
pancreas so the season 4 episode
schedule is probably going to be very
similar to the season 1 schedule where
they air episodes weekly up until their
Christmas episode take 2 to 3 weeks off
and then come back for the rest of the
episodes the second week in January
because this year the premiere is
probably November 17th that works out to
5 episodes before the end of the year
first half of the season they go on
break they come back in January for the
second half of the season the rest of
the five episodes give or take so they
also overlap with the Super Bowl so
there might be some Super Bowl
integrations or funny promos that they
released for all that stuff there's
gonna be so much stuff happening in
December this year there's also a rumor
that The Witcher Netflix episodes are
gonna be dropping the week before
Christmas so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you'll see all
those videos but looking ahead to season
5 they might also choose to release
season 5 at the same time next year as
they do season 4 this year if they feel
like the season 4 episodes perform
better more people watch them they make
more money on the merch sales their new
deal with Turner does allow them to
deliver more than 10
episodes per season but it's still up to
Adult Swim in the network to decide how
many episodes per season they release in
when they released the seasons if they
don't want to do November next year they
could do a summer release because it
does sound like they will have season
five episodes ready to go by next summer
right now unless they say something
different I'm assuming ten episodes per
season for six more years but they could
speed that up and release multiple
blocks of episodes per year if they have
enough episodes in the can everybody
post your season four theories in the
comments below I'll be doing bonus
videos and Easter eggs all year long if
you have a special video you want to
request just write it in the comments
below congratulations Ryan Ramirez
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Rick and Morty video please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your details usually you have to do
that on desktop I don't think that that
shows up on mobile everybody click here
for my last big Rick and Morty season 4
teaser trailer and clips and click here
for my new avatar the last airbender
Netflix series video that's right brand
new avatar series coming to Netflix next
year thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome i'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]